You know, it's very interesting how here in
the United States, when it comes to the virus
and in particular when it comes to vaccines,
which we will be talking about significantly
really starting now and expecting
approval of vaccines in the U.S.,
potentially even with within hours or in the next
few days into twenty twenty one within this area
of vaccination. And really, with the virus
in general, reality is increasingly the exact
opposite of what the Trump administration tells
us that it is. And this is to some degree been the
case for a while now. But it's increasingly
glaring and we can sort of go back to the
beginning as far as vaccines are concerned. And
remember that for months, Donald Trump and this
administration have been telling us that his
vaccine initiative called Operation Warp Speed,
is the only way to get vaccines ready quickly,
that without operation, warp speed vaccines could
take five to six years to get. As he said in that
clip I played for you yesterday from Tuesday's
vaccine summit, it used to take infinity to get
a vaccine, whatever that means, until operation
warp speed, which is a strange thing to say, but
the truth is very different. The truth has been
and continues to be that the reason we're getting
vaccines for coronavirus relatively quickly
is that the ones we're seeing now, Pfizer,
Biotech, Oxford, AstraZeneca, Moderna,
they're built on an MRN, a platform. This is
much faster to work with, much faster to develop
than the traditional vaccines which are based on
weakened or dead virus. And we also have those
coming. This is an important thing to remember.
In twenty, twenty one, we're expecting there
will be new coronavirus vaccines as well based
on that weakened or dead virus platform. Those
are underdevelopment. They still take longer.
Operation warp speed is not accelerated those
in any way either. And of course, Donald Trump's
claims never pass the sniff test because the
vaccine development that was happening in other
countries was taking place just as quickly as in
the United States. And of course, the development,
for example, in the UK of the Oxford vaccine
had nothing to do with Operation Warp Speed. And
you don't even need to look at other countries,
because even within the United States, the
vaccination development under the A platform
by companies not taking operation warp speed
money happened just as quickly as those who did
take Operation Warp Speed Money. So it was very
clear that this wasn't passing the sniff test.
And fascinatingly, this has now come to be flipped
on its head because despite Trump's bragging about
Operation warp speed being the one and only
sole path to developing a vaccine quickly, both
the United Kingdom and Canada have beaten
the United States to approved coronavirus
vaccines. Earlier this week, I told you that
the United Kingdom approved its vaccine and is
already vaccinating people. It's vaccine.
They approved the Pfizer biotech vaccine
originally developed in Germany. They are already
vaccinating people. There are now concerns about
allergic reactions, which are still early. And
we're exploring whether there are folks with prior
allergic reactions to vaccines who maybe should
not get this one very early. But they're starting
to build that data, starting to vaccinate
people. Now it's Canada as well. Canada's health
department yesterday gave emergency approval for
the Pfizer biotech vaccine. So it's no longer
rhetoric. Trump has been bragging for months
about imaginary accomplishments on vaccines.
We had the sense that the bragging was not based.
In fact, now today, December 10th, twenty twenty,
the United Kingdom has an approved coronavirus
vaccine and is vaccinating people. Canada has
an approved coronavirus vaccine and will have
vaccinations happening within within days. And
the US does not yet have an approved coronavirus
vaccine. Now, it should be just a matter of days
or even hours. The FDA panel meeting is already
happening. I was watching some of it earlier today
during this meeting. At its conclusion, they
are going to be voting as to whether to grant
emergency use authorization for the Pfizer
biotech vaccine. I believe it's December
17th, a week from today that we will have
a meeting of the FDA about emergency use
authorization for the Moderna vaccine. So in
ten days, we could have two approved vaccines.
Right now we do not. And so the question is,
why does our guy constantly brag, but get out,
done in the end on the facts? Humility seems
not to be an option, particularly when he ends
up getting embarrassed by the facts every time
he just comes up with more lies. And remember
that Donald Trump and his administration promised
us three hundred million vaccine doses in twenty
twenty you. It's hard to keep track because they
constantly move the goalposts. But the promise was
three hundred million doses. By the end of
twenty twenty, they failed, plain and simple,
and now, unfortunately, and I don't take any
pleasure in this because of Donald Trump opting
out of securing an additional hundred thousand
Pfizer biotech doses when given the option in late
summer, we are going to be at a deficit in terms
of being able to really get people vaccinated. So
updated timeline, a first vaccine expected to
be approved in the next hours or days. Second
vaccine, December 17th meeting, assuming both get
approved. We are looking at vaccination for about
20 million people in the next few weeks. Now,
remember, there is this 28 day period from when
you get your first dose to when you have the full
power of the vaccine, a dose one tends to get you
somewhere between 60 and 80 percent immunity
success dose to gets you to the ninety five, seven
days after that second dose has been has been
received. So by February 1st, we may have six or
so percent of the backs of the population immune.
Remember, the vaccinations will start sooner,
but it takes a while to build the immunity and
it's a start. The US recently has been averaging
more than two hundred thousand cases per day.
Remember, Dr. Fauci told us months ago, you know,
we could get if we're not careful, we could
get to 100 K per day. Half the country said no,
no, no. Now we're at 200000 cases per day. And
deaths, meanwhile, tragically continue to soar.
I told you we could be close to a 9/11 worth of
deaths every day. But now we are there several
days this week between twenty nine hundred and
three thousand deaths per day in the United
States, inconceivably tragic, by the way. Yet
people still just don't even know what's going on.
Even in Massachusetts yesterday, I left a
bakery required to wear a mask. So I did got my
croissants. And as I was walking out with my mask,
a mask, this guy walks by me. I tweeted about
this and says, pathetic masks wearing a blue
lives matter shirt, by way, just as a detail.
Also wearing a blue lives matter shirt, this
guy. So we have a lot of people who still don't
even get it. Now, as far as vaccines go, the big
tragedy is the death and the human and economic
cost as a result of the missteps. And also, we
can't forget the missteps at every opportunity
by the administration started with denying the
seriousness of the pandemic. They refused to wear
masks until much too late. Trump turned down the
one hundred million doses of the Pfizer vaccine
from Pfizer over the summer. Now, we're not going
to get our second delivery of Pfizer vaccines
potentially until June of twenty twenty one.
They failed on the second stimulus. They were
regularly outdone in terms of stimulus by
other countries, other wealthy countries,
OKd countries doing better, both in terms of
suppressing and in terms of stimulus. So it's
sad. It's tragic. It's pathetic. I don't know what
the right word is, sort of an all of the above,
but if there is any optimistic news, it's that
we're starting to get the vaccines and soon
Trump will be gone and we will have something a
little more sensible, a guiding us through this.